hi I'm Nicholas Holt and this is how I
became Renfield hi I'm Nicholas Cage and
this is how I became Dracula
last time I saw myself in in the makeup
uh Christian Tinsley did a wonderful job
designing the look of renfell first of
all trying to bail me out make me look
like someone who'd been working for
Dracula for a hundred years and and how
that would affect his complexion and
self-care I suppose that's something
that Renfield hasn't had time for
himself at all in this time and that
even went back to the costume and the
lovely details that we had within that
of like the fraying of the suit and and
those things which then for a character
you can see you know where you might
pick at nervously on on your suit
trouser and things like that so it's all
little details
um that then hopefully inform the the
complete character ultimately well the
first time I began to see what the
character would look like for Dracula
was a makeup and a wardrobe rehearsal
and Nick Holt and I got a lot done in
that rehearsal we started improvising
and playing off of each other and I I
saw the style of the clothing these sort
of Velveteen suits red and black
Velveteen suits and I got to work with
the makeup and it really informed the
performance and also having time with
Nick to see where he was going to go
because he's setting the pace of the
movie as a supporting actor I want to
fit within the flavor he's bringing and
keep everything in Balance that's my job
and so these uh early uh wardrobe hair
and makeup rehearsals really helped with
that there were different versions to
the makeup and I think there were about
three different looks for Dracula the
most uh intensive was the what we call
the Picasso appearance which was about
eight hours in the chair and about 20
pounds of Mega both the face and the
body
and then the other ones gradually got
less time in the chair so from like
eight to four to two
but each one of the looks helped inform
the character and the approach to the
character and then even the timing of
the character I could tell where I
needed to go for each look in terms of
performance acting with the fangs was a
bit of a learning curve because
Christian intensely a great makeup
artist he wanted it to look like Lon
Chaney in London after midnight so there
was a tremendous amount of ceramic
material in my mouth and yet I still
wanted to speak elegantly and eloquently
as Count Dracula would so I would take
them home with me home being my hotel
room in New Orleans
and play with it and talk and rehearse
with it so I could get control of the
speaking as as best as I could sorry to
interrupt are you okay I need to get out
of a toxic relationship I mean the
brilliant thing about playing Renfield
is there is a lot
um you can draw from in terms of the
original novel and then and then that
has given you kind of a backdrop to the
character because it's so far removed
and then time has has gone on so much
that by the time we meet the character
in this story you get to have all that
it's kind of as information to to craft
it all around and then and the original
films and other performances that people
have delivered as well so I would listen
to uh Dwight Fry's laugh a lot because I
thought that was such a beautiful
performance he gave in that film and
that that laugh is so iconic that it was
something that I wanted to to try and
pay homage to a little bit
um so those were kind of a few of the
little details
um that I was trying to pick up on well
Inspirations for Dracula for me uh
predominantly started with whatever was
coming out uh empathic from being in the
zone with Nick Holt and sometimes I
surprise myself but I think in terms of
the look for Dracula Christopher Lee was
the model in terms of Behavioral
Inspirations I would say that August
Coppola was the main source my father
with a little uh and Bancroft as Mrs
Robinson sprinkled in the thing that I
found interesting about the character
that I wanted to bring that was new I
suppose was this sense of regret and and
the mistakes he made so a lot of the
time the Renfield character in the in
the novel I suppose in previous
iterations you know you don't see the
effect It ultimately has on him perhaps
so I guess that's the thing of like
where it leads to 100 years down the
line where suddenly he's had time to
reflect and see where this journey this
this charming relationship that he got
into what it's led to and and how he
comes to terms with that and and himself
and and what he's chosen the Brazilian
thing knew I was trying to find for
Dracula it was a uh a fusion between
that which is genuinely creepy and
spooky and also funny and how I could
blend those two is that it wasn't just
comedy rip or tape per se but it was
fused through a vessel of actual Menace
and that was a balance to find and then
also I think the element of the curse
you know he's stuck doing this and there
are things worse than death and he's
stuck getting his heart broken over and
over and having to drink blood again and
again I think that's something I was
trying to find I will no longer tolerate
abuse I deserve happiness
okay you deserve only suffering defining
the relationship is difficult to Define
in in a clear way because it's so
intertwined they really do depend on
each other and have grown so accustomed
to each other and there is a lot of love
between them and and care and then
there's also there's fear and there's a
toxic abusive kind of element to it
where they they really know how to push
each other's buttons and and and and and
bring out the worst and best in each of
each other I suppose the brilliant thing
about working with Nick on it is that he
brings so many different elements and
and Inspirations to Dracula that it was
you you were never quite sure From
renfield's perspective
what you were going to get if he was
going to kill you with kindness and
charm or if it was going to be a moment
that he would lash out and hurt you and
that was really great for me as an actor
because I would watch Nick and kind of
the unexpected would happen and he would
throw out dialogue and new ideas and as
his Renfield that's something that he's
always kind of trying to put out fires
and so that's what I was trying to do as
an actor just kind of keep up and be
playful in those moments you know the
collaboration with Nicole is something
that I'd wanted to revisit I was fully
aware of his ability and his Poise and
his chops as an actor on the weatherman
and I'm not surprised at the star he's
subsequently become and I wanted to get
back in a movie with him
um I am very much in support of Nick
Holt in this movie as Dracula and so it
was important for me because the lead
actor is always setting the pace of any
movie you're in and it was important for
me to take whatever little time we had I
mean he was very busy in fact learning
an incredible dance number which didn't
make it in the movie sadly you'll see it
on Blu-ray but he's a hell of a dancer
but he was busy so any chance I got to
look at sets with him or do uh makeup or
wardrobe rehearsal with him I would
start improvising and throwing launch
just to see where he was going and what
flavor he was bringing so I could
support that so that those were very uh
helpful days that we could we could
explore together I was taken by how he
reinvented the Renfield character I I
think this is a completely new take on
Renfield this hasn't been seen before
and it helped me find where Dracula
could go in terms of comedy and also
turn on a dime and be vulnerable which
is what Nick was doing so I was trying
to match him to support the context of
his presentation
others the Lord of death so you bring
and people to eat well I do other stuff
like what washes Cape the Cape is dry
clean only strictly I'm most excited for
people to see that that blend of horror
and action and comedy and and hopefully
yeah have laughs whilst also this
emotional core of this Dynamic and this
relationship being unraveled I am
hopeful that audience they will go on a
ride and they will have a lot of fun
it'll be an unpredictable roller coaster
they'll be laughing and then they'll be
screaming they don't know which when
they should do either so they'll be
knocked around a little bit but I'm also
very excited that they're going to see
this new version of Renfield which is
normally played in a kind of grotesque
manner now where Nick is Reinventing it
with a very comedic and also vulnerable
presentation and a Charming presentation
I think it's a very fresh and very
original take
[Music]
thank you